New friends are all around the world.
Some are like you, and some are different.
I am Chang-Yong, and I am ten.
My family lives in South Korea.
I like going to school and playing ball.
My best jacket is made of silk.
My favorite food is barbecued beef.
Jessica is my name.
I live in Australia.
I am six.
I live with my mother and grandmother.
My mother is a cook.
I love to watch kangaroos hop around.
I am Natasha, and I am seven.
My home is an apartment in Moscow, Russia.
I like dancing.
I wear a fur hat and coat in winter.
I play in the snow.
I love to eat pancakes.
I live in Tanzania.
Manka is my name.
We live in a hut with a grass roof.
My father takes care of our cows.
I get water from a well.
I make toys out of clay.
I am Kipanik.
I live in Canada, where it is cold.
My dogs pull me on my sled.
I play hockey with my friends.
Our dads hunt animals for food.
I like meat with ketchup.
How are you like these children.
How are you different.